majoration de 12,9 pour cent des
allocations familiales à partir
d'aujourd'hui c'est ce que vient
d'annoncer michel durafour le ministre
du travail au cours d'une conférence de
presse
une mesure qui intéresse près de quatre
millions trois cent mille familles
un france et le prix depuis ce matin la
plupart des quotidien parisien le figaro
l'aurore combat le parisien libéré
françois vous les paierez désormais un
franc l'humanité passe de 1 franc
en vain le monde et le quotidienne paris
qui coûtait déjà un franc cette
augmentation est due aux charges accrues
de la profession notamment la hausse des
prix de l'énergie et du papier